Hi, welcome to your tour of Udacity. Let's get started. So here's our main
office area. As you see, it's really open so we can all work together as a
team. And luckily everybody here is really creative, and that allows us to come
up with awesome ideas and make the creative classes that you guys love. Let's
go to next place, this is the side of the office we come to when we need to get
away from the hustle and bustle of the other side of the office we can relax on
bean bags or on one of the couches and meet up with people and discuss really
big ideas. This is the area where we all come to kind of distress and play
different games like foosball and ping pong and again enjoy working with each
other, here you can see we have a fully soft kitchen with all the drinks and
all the snacks we could ever want and this is the area were we have lunch
together as a team everyday for some co-worker bonding time. And we can even
bring dogs to the office so we have puppies to play with